mais vous l'avez entendu dans les
informations du jour c'est la septième
semaine olympique et paralympique
partout en France et notamment à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines dans 13
exactement 480 jours l'agglomération
accueillera quelques-unes des épreuves
des JO de Paris 2024 avec des sites
olympiques la colline d'Élancourt le
golf national et le vélodrome national
qui a en plus accueilli aujourd'hui ce
vélo Drôme un premier rendez-vous dans
le cadre de la Semaine Olympique on le
disait tout à l'heure on va en parler
avec Maxime Lucas qui a changé de
promotion de la vie sportive à 50 ans en
Yvelines déjà peut-être un petit tour de
table et ce qui est un engouement
particulier de votre part j'imagine le
journaliste de sport que vous êtes
nickel avec cet échange olympique qui
arrive on est à 480 jours désormais de
cette échéance olympique on se dit
surtout que ça arrive ça va arriver très
vite il reste peu de temps d'ici les
Jeux Olympiques et ça va monter en
puissance il va avoir des tests events
qui vont être organisés sur le
territoire je crois que en septembre il
y aura notamment sur la colline
d'Élancourt un test Steven donc comment
on attend ça avec impatience Céline
c'est un événement qui met en valeur en
plus le territoire moi c'est surtout
l'équitation qui me qui me donne envie
romain du gars un regard vers le passé
avec les archives départementales
forcément un regard vers le futur aussi
avec cette échéance olympique qui arrive
tout près tout proche des archives des
Archives départementales tout à fait et
justement enfin on aura l'occasion de
reparler mais on développe on a
développé une application de d'enquête
géolocalisées et
en tant que tel c'est une possibilité
d'itinérance sur le territoire donc
c'est quelque part un parcours sportif
qu'on proposera enfin voilà les archives
départementales vont se mobiliser
également dans le cadre des JO donc pour
faire remonter l'engouement cette
semaine olympique et paralympique 7e
édition Maxime Lucas quel est l'objectif
c'est justement de sensibiliser aux
valeurs de l'olympisme c'est ça alors
les journées olympiques enfin la Semaine
Olympique et paralympiques c'est c'est
organisé par Paris 2024 et l'éducation
nationale
avec comme premier objectif de mettre
plus de sport dans le quotidien des des
enfants et aussi de pouvoir leur
transmettre le l'engouement qui va y
avoir au niveau des des Jeux Olympiques
c'est les plus jeunes sont très éloignés
de ça et ne prennent pas encore plein de
conscience de ce qui va se passer chez
eux en 2024 surtout pour des jeunes
habitants de l'agglomération et c'est
pour ça que 50 ans en Yvelines mais les
moyens pour mettre en place des actions
dans le cadre de cette semaine olympique
le premier objectif pour 50 ans de
Linkedin c'est de que ces enfants
s'assent s'approprient les les jeux qui
vont se dérouler chez eux cette
génération 2024 qu'elle soit au fait
qu'il y a il y a des JO avait bien
entendu dans dans un peu plus d'un an
maintenant en France alors la thématique
cette année je disais tout à l'heure
c'est l'inclusion donc sensibiliser les
jeunes mais on va y associer aussi les
aînés les seniors des EHPAD de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines vous allez
profiter de cette semaine à 50 ans en
ligne pour organiser des rencontres
justement entre jeunes et personnes
âgées du territoire alors c'était le cas
d'ailleurs cet après-midi au Vélodrome
national de 50 ans en Yvelines avec un
rendez-vous qui s'est vaut mieux
regarder ces quelques réactions
collectées sur place par Patrick Jacques
de Dixmude il a pu justement collecter
quelques réactions de participants des
jeunes et des seniors associés pour cet
événement par exemple en vacances j'ai
toujours plein de jeunes avec moi et
bien souvent il y en a qui disent il
n'est pas il y a un qui me dit adieu
j'aurais été content que tu sois mon
grand-père est-ce que j'amuse tout le
monde je suis très dynamique voilà
parce que j'ai quand même eu besoin de
lui pour tenir un peu libre je pense que
c'est la nouvelle méthode depuis
quelques temps de
mettre des personnes
des seniors avec la nouvelle génération
pour qu'il s'apprenne aussi bien de nos
connaissances que l'inverse de leur
facilité de pouvoir bouger ça nous
rajeunit c'est très bien c'est très bien
j'ai eu tiens je te présente ma petite
camomille
enfin quand c'est Camille mais c'était
mieux
le coup de sourire cet après-midi au
vélo de route nationale vous l'avez dit
sensibiliser les jeunes mais là on y
associe des personnes âgées pourquoi ce
choix pour pour l'agglomération c'est
sous cet angle qu'on a souhaité de
traiter d'inclusion
et c'est pas le seul angle sur lequel on
va se baser cette semaine
je sais pas si on va revenir sur le
programme des actions mais il était
important pour nous d'associer les moins
jeunes à ces actions et travailler avec
cette résidence autonome ou les EHPAD
avec lesquels on va travailler à la fin
de la semaine pour montrer que le sport
voilà ça peut être un super lien entre
des jeunes des des personnes plus âgées
on a vu voilà des gens qui ne se serait
pas forcément connus autre parc que cet
après-midi voilà elles étaient
rassemblant audio il y avait un jeune et
une personne âgée c'est ça c'est ça
alors sur l'après-midi ils ont commencé
par visiter le Vélodrome pour la plupart
c'était la première fois qu'il rentrait
dans le dans le vélo drone ou alors ils
étaient venus se faire vacciner mais là
ils ont vraiment pu découvrir le
vélodrome découvrir on leur a présenté
ce qui était le cyclisme sur piste un
vélo de cyclisme sur piste et ensuite il
y avait oui tout un atelier de sportifs
où ça se faisait en binôme avec un élève
de cette classe de Coignières et une
personne âgée et ensuite ils ont terminé
par par une visite du Stadium BMX où ils
ont pu assister à un entraînement de
l'équipe de France oui parce que sur ce
site du Vélodrome on rappelle les
épreuves de cyclisme sur piste et on est
juste à côté du Stadium de BMX où se
dérouleront bien sûr ces épreuves
olympiques de BMX ça ne va pas s'arrêter
là cette semaine il y a tout un
programme qui est qui sera déployé par
50 en Yvelines c'est ça c'est une
semaine où on va pas arrêter on a décidé
d'avoir des actions sur toute la semaine
et surtout les jours jusqu'à vendredi
demain on sera au golf national avec en
s'associant avec le Golf National et la
Fédération Française de Golf et cette
fois-ci le l'inclusion sera traité sous
l'angle de du paragolf avec la présence
d'Aurélien Lacour qui est para golfeur
de très très haut niveau et il y aura
également des ateliers de golf ou les
enfants seront mis en situation de
handicap pour pouvoir se mettre dans la
position de personne en situation de
handicap et par ce biais là en traite on
traite le handicap donc finalement
différents points de vue sur la sur
l'inclusion indifférent de manière
d'aborder le sujet c'est ça et on va
poursuivre la semaine ensuite mercredi
on sera de retour au Vélodrome cette
fois-ci on est plus avec des des
scolaires de primaires mais avec des
collégiens et des lycéens on s'associe à
et on présentera l'inclusion sur la
thème du parasyclisme avec la présence
du WC de Sky le club de vélo de
d'Élancourt qui qui a des une section
dédiée aux para cyclistes chez eux et
qui présentera cette discipline
et ensuite jeudi et vendredi on se
déplacera dans des EHPAD à chaque fois
avec une classe pour la question d'une
fresque
il y aura des moments sportifs et une
fresque sur le thème des jeux voilà qui
pourra être laissé après aux EHPAD
Michael vous avez une question
que c'est très bien en tout cas de
mettre en place ce lien
intergénérationnel parce que les JO
c'est vraiment pour tout le monde donc
forcément ça va concerner tout le monde
sur le territoire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et des
Yvelines enfin c'était impressionnant
d'avoir les mêmes réactions sur
l'inclinaison de la piste que que ce
soit les enfants ou les personnes
âgées cet après-midi au Vélodrome quand
elles sont arrivées elles ont toutes eu
cet effet waouh de découvrir cette
inclinaison et c'était les mêmes les
mêmes grands yeux face aux entraînements
de l'équipe de France de BMX derrière
donc on voit que le sport est un super
vecteur pour pour parler à plein de gens
de qui sont tous différents d'ailleurs
c'est mieux que Michael vous parliez de
cette ouverture à tout le monde puisque
le prochain gros temps fort aussi en
matière de limpisme ce sera la journée
olympique qui va aussi arriver pour
l'agglomération d'habitude ouvert
uniquement scolaire et cette année
l'ambition c'est l'ouvrir à tout le
monde ouais c'est ça alors la journée
olympique
il y a une date officielle qui a une
date mondiale qui est le 23 juin donc
cette année ça tombe à un vendredi ça se
déroulera au golf national et le
vendredi on le dédie comme d'hab comme
les autres années au scolaires et par
contre on poursuivra le samedi avec les
mêmes partenaires qui sont des
fédérations des ligues et des comités
mais aussi des clubs locaux et là on
invite tout le monde ça sera on verra
tous sans inscription au golf national
et là tout le monde pourra s'essayer un
maximum de sport il sera possible de
faire de l'escalade du rugby enfin tout
ça sur un même site et au cours d'une
même journée et en plus l'agglomération
présentera tout un tas de d'actions
dédiées à l'accueil des jeux un
programme volontaire pour être
volontaire sur les jeux un nouveau site
internet tu auras plein de choses
d'annoncées ce 24 juin redonnez-nous la
date le 24 juin samedi 24 juin au golf
national on voit les précédentes
éditions de cette journée olympique très
très rapidement Michael ce qu'on a et
vous attendez combien de personnes sur
cette journée-là
il y a énormément de monde on sait qu'on
est en capacité d'accueillir plus de 500
personnes en simultanées donc on n'a pas
de limite de jauge sur la journée l'idée
c'est de sensibiliser le maximum de 50
ninois de famille 50 images au sport
mais aussi de leur parler JO de voir
leur proposer de leur présenter ce qui
va se passer chez eux dans on sera le 24
juin à j-400 de la première épreuve
accueillie sur 50 ans
olympique merci Maxime Lucas d'être venu
parler de tous ces sujets en plateau
chargé de promotion de la vie sportive à
50 ans